>>Hi, YouTube.
Here I am, back again.
Last time I talked to you was about the water
issue.
And I'm happy to say that we are still talking
about it, that we are
not only talking about it, this time we were
able to make a big, big
step.
We took the last year and we developed a tool,
scientific tool, in
order to be able to help politicians to make
the right decision on how
to solve this problem.
And we have presented this now to governments.
And I'm very happy to say that we have found
seven governments who are
now willing to work with us, together with
McKinsey, and to bring this
tools into practice.
And to hope during the next year to try to
solve in some watersheds,
this problem.
So I think this was a great way forward from
last time I talked to you
when I was still talking about the problem
but now we have solutions.
And I hope that in a year from now I'm able
to talk to you about how
this solution has been put into practice.